hello and welcome once again to Android
design in action I'm your host Roman
Nurik I hi my name is Nick butcher
and today we have a special episode
where we're going to talk about actually
we're gonna dive into one of the apps
that was previously covered on the GDG
app clinic Oslo in Norway for those of
you that aren't very good with geography
and then we're gonna dive into some some
details on design consistency
specifically kind of talking about when
you should think about your brand versus
holo and Android Android design
principles and kind of when windows meet
so with that let's get started so we're
gonna be talking about one app today I'm
probably not gonna pronounce it right
but it's Finn I know it's kind of like a
market type app like I almost like an
eBay I'd say and again everything was in
Norwegian so I wasn't able to fully
grasp the the full extent of the app but
it is kind of like a market type app
that lets you look at products find
products it's very it's got a very deep
hierarchy it's got a very deep hierarchy
so you know there are lots of lots of
different parts of the app which we'll
talk about but yeah so let's just dive
in so here's one of the first screens
that you'll see in the app you'll notice
that it's kind of like a an intro screen
it you know it's very nice it kind of
introduces you to the the the main
character the main I guess spokesperson
for this for this company this kind of
cute cat character and then you
immediately jump into content which is
nice there's no you know heavy
introduction screen there's no you know
like dashboard pattern you're
immediately get content and this primary
content area is all about kind of posts
that this that this company releases I
believe and then for each posters kind
of I guess listings associated with
those so you'll see here that you know
there's there's this one post that talks
about something that's on the market
right now I believe it's a property for
sale or for
and then there's another about wedding
dresses or something like that so
there's a couple of other details in the
app which we'll talk throughout talk
about throughout but we also you know
wanted to talk about some of the some of
the things that we decided to change
some of the things that we decided to
you know tweak around with so the first
is you know you'll notice that there's
this kind of top bar it's a it's not
really an action bar it has the logo in
the middle whereas the action wear
usually has a leguminous and the left
and it has you know affordances for
search search as well as filter and then
login which is on the right there's also
a couple of other things you'll see here
there's this you know for each one of
these posts you can actually click this
button here to to take you to all the
listings related to that post versus if
there's only one item you'll only just
see one here there's no kind of arrow
there so we've found that a little bit
confusing that there is there are two
different states the two different
places that this area could lead you to
either just the single listing or the
full set of listings okay so let's see
what we did with this actually before we
do that Nick you have any any thoughts
anything to share no I mean overall is
it kind of quite clean and flat design
which is very modern and nice-looking
but it's just a few things which kind of
didn't quite sit right for me in the you
know Android pattern so let's see what
we've done with the screen yep so the
first thing we did was we added a proper
action bar my shadow zoom in here later
a proper action bar we also added a
navigation drawer which we'll talk about
in just a second but we also you know
tweaked a lot of the metrics and that's
one of the things that I definitely tend
to harp on when I when I look at apps is
metric spacing font sizes margins
padding's things like that you'll notice
that in the original you know the the
text I guess the titles are kind of
cramped with the image to the left and
then the font size is kind of vary
throughout so one of the things we did
was we standardized some of the font
sizes as well as some of the margins we
use a standard 16 bit
kind of base grid we have 16-bit margins
throughout we have we use eight dip in
some places Biel notice that's just a
little more you know properly spaced out
in my opinion we also obviously did some
tweaks here in terms of you know rather
than using these card style boxes to
hold you know single post with its
associated listings we kind of use this
this almost like a section header
styling where you have a gray background
for for the post itself the text of the
post or the comment I guess and then
each of the items which is really the
thing you want to pop the most it has a
slightly different styling of white a
lighter background we also in the action
bar we moved search into its proper
position at the top right we left the
overflow for things like my profile
which is something that was given a lot
of prominence here but we decided to
relegate it to the to the overflow since
that's kind of a very common place to
put it and then we added the navigation
drawer which we'll show in a second
before we move on to the next screen
Nick Andy and I'm a particularly big fan
of typography I find screens with which
having you know a large range of
different type sizes on them can feel
messy to me it's almost like people
trying too hard to communicate the
information hierarchy and it ends up
just getting a little bit confused I
think you've done a really nice job here
of cleaning up the typographic palette
here so using fewer type sizes but using
like fun weight in color instead to
communicate what is important and you
know what is less important right now so
I think that's a very nice job I also
really like the little profile photos
the doctor lines I think that works
really well to communicate that you know
the entry the white background post is
you know a child of the kind of
announcement place yeah and so that the
the profile photos are very small in the
in the current version you know it's
definitely something that when you went
possible when you have you know imagery
when you have a high-resolution photos
things like that you should definitely
make you know give them more space than
than you normally
may so definitely you know consider
consider using larger images or possible
I think that's one of my takeaways from
then Google i/o this year from Alex Bob
walks talk on cognitive science you have
a special part of your brain which is
great at pausing and photo because
pictures of people and recognize them in
kind of light almost instantaneously for
page rather than have to scan through
and read name and so on so maybe not
with a cat photo but if this is going to
be like a person off and then I think
making the most of those images is
exactly so let's move on to the the next
screen which is the actually this is
just another example as you scroll down
you would obviously see more items and
and you'd have the overflow which would
contain my profile settings help about
the standard stuff to you but there yeah
it's worth recapping here as well like
the rules we kind of tend to think about
for when things should be in action
which is you know immediately available
on the action bar on when things you get
to motive I'd say something like my
profile is gonna be an uncommon action
you're not going to be clicking into
that many times right so that probably
should always go into the action
overflow similar to how health and
settings and about would always go in
the action overflow as uncommon actions
and you wouldn't want to have to promote
this to a kind of action item even if
there was facing on a larger device
because it's like not a common action
another thing I wanted to mention is
that if you if you know if you want to
kind of encourage the user to log in to
create an account for your app you know
using the overflow for that it's
probably not a good idea probably not
gonna get too much engagement there but
what you could do is have like a like a
butter bar or something like a
dismissable butter bar show up that says
you know along the bottom of the screen
it says hey you know if you log in you
get this this and this you know value or
you know just kind of immediately
explain the benefits rather than showing
like an icon always in the available on
screen just make it contextual if you
want the user to log in or register make
sure that they see it kind of a nice big
prominent bar that they can also dismiss
if they don't you know really want to
log in so let's move on to the next
actually this is this is the scroll down
version you notice that rather than
having this extra arrow here to show all
the listings we just have like an all
listings item at the very bottom so
you'd show maybe three or four items as
kind of a summary of the post and then
at the bottom you click on all this that
you touch all this things to take you
there
so let's look at the the drawer so you
have right now if you if you touch that
top left search icon you get this I
guess it's kind of like a navigation
drawer to the left it shows you the list
of categories as well as a list of
recent searches along with search itself
so search is kind of part of this bar
and it makes sense in terms of proximity
right the the search bar is right next
to the recent searches however I mean
it's it's a somewhat of an uncommon
place for search users really expect
search to be in the action bar
immediately available not two touches
away but immediately kind of one touch
away and and this is it's not really
violating any any strong semantic rules
for the navigation genre there aren't
any actions in here except for search
but it is kind of pushing the content
over pushing the the top bar over and so
in terms of the interaction itself it is
it's not really violating the guidelines
but it's not adhering to the to the
guidelines that we have set out so what
we decided to do is see what this look
would look like with a proper new
navigation drawer so you have you know
home at the top which is kind of your
your stream per se and then each of the
other things are still represented there
we also added a couple of things like
like section headers to make sure that
it's clear what you're looking at and
yeah you could do the same thing as you
can like dismiss recent searches you can
you know you can switch between the
different categories and things of that
but the the the core point here is that
you know since the action bar doesn't
slide out of the way search is still
accessible search is still in action
that's there in the action bar because
it's globally relevant it's not
contextually relevant to the screen that
the navigation drawer is hiding so it's
totally fine to leave that action there
when a navigation drawer is exposed okay
let's see so what else did we do here so
once you jump into once you actually
perform a search let's say you you press
one of these categories or you click on
a recent search you get taken to this
screen which again has those persistent
top left and top right I guess jars
available and it also lets you sort so
the the issue here is that it's you know
there isn't a concept of really
hierarchy and you're you're kind of like
just at another flat part of
you're just on another part of the app
that happens to be search results so
there's no quick way besides pressing
the back button to get home so what we
did here was we we actually you know
mirrored a lot of the things from we
copied a lot of the things from the
original or the current app we still
have you know obviously the images on
the left and the the metadata on the
right and you know obviously what we we
did some typographic treatments there
but we kept the navigation drawer I'll
actually talk about that in a second and
then we moved the common actions of
things like filtering and sorting which
we'll talk about in a second into the
action bar in there in a normal place
now in terms of the navigation drawer
some folks may may think oh why isn't
there an UP button here now the reason
for for this and this is kind of
contentious you could probably go either
way on it my thinking here was that
since these recent searches are
represented in the navigation drawer so
they're here at pizza or wedding dresses
since they're represented there they
should actually they should actually
those screens that you get taken to when
you press those should appear in the
navigation drawer or should have the
navigation drawer affordance and this is
in accordance with the guidelines that
we have set out so if you touch
something in a navigation drawer and you
get taken to a new screen that screen
should have access that the same
navigation bar so you could probably go
either way I mean a lot of folks think
that you know on search screens you
could have an up but you should have an
UP button and you know I guess this is
just one way to do it and then also you
have access to the refine search so if
you actually want to filter further you
could you know you could touch it up
there and then you know everything else
in the screen so Nick before we move on
any comments or I know just a few
comments on the on the visual designers
well I think even a nice job of
tightening up the visual design on this
I think especially the treatment of the
images and having them basically flush
with the side and that and then below
item works really really well so
basically using as much space as you can
to show you know rich imagery which is
much quicker than you know to scan than
a textual description so I think that's
really really nice that you give them
that room to to show off cool ok so
let's look at a couple details here the
first is the first right is that if you
touch the recent search like wedding
dresses that could be populated in the
top so that could effectively be an
editable title and if you if you move on
here so you'll notice that sort is a
submenu so when you touch this sort I
con you get a list of sort options
accrual of ins price availability these
should actually have radio buttons next
to them that's a design issue kind of a
bug there these should have radio
buttons showing what the current sort is
as well and then the most interesting
thing that part of this I'd say is the
filtering so actually I lied a bit when
you touch on let me see if I can go back
here when you touch here right so when
you touch here you actually don't get
immediately taken to a to the results
screen you get taken to a filter
interstitial first so you actually get
taken to wow this is looking to see if I
can get to it
you actually get taken here first so as
soon as you touch a category you get
taken to a filter screen which then you
can obviously modify and then once you
choose the right filters you can swipe
over to see the results so instead of
instead of having another left pane what
we decided to do is you know filtering
is really kind of like an action it's
it's the action
the act of filtering your current set of
results so we decided to do is move this
over to the right as a right drawer it's
kind of something that that's on the on
the right hand side like a filter or you
know you could do something like a layer
selection if you're looking at a map or
something like that so we moved
filtering to the right you'll notice
that it's not just a drawer it's not
just a drawer it's actually also
available as an action button so if you
if you touch the filter icon there it
actually should expand and collapse the
filter pane this is very similar to how
Google Plus or Google one today do
notifications so the idea here is that
instead of being taken directly to the
search results you can actually take the
user to the search results screen but
immediately expose the right-hand filter
jar and once they make the selections
they could just wipe it out of the way
I'm beside this like the idea of
changing the content of the navigation
drawer
I'm not a huge fan of I mean it's such
an important facility to be able to
navigate around the application the idea
of having this kind of different modes
in which you're in and it's kind of like
lack of stability or Maisie do I'm not a
huge fan of it so I think it's much
cleaner and also the fact that filtering
is tends to be an action it's not really
navigation it's kind of acting upon the
data you've all you you know navigate it
to there it definitely maps to an action
and therefore I've kind of like the
right-hand side of the action bar and
aren't in Android Model T it is much
better exactly yeah so you'll notice
here that there's kind of like an UP
button ins or a back button inside of
the navigation drawer anytime you see
that definitely try to avoid that the
only type of hierarchy you should have
within the drawer is collapsible
sections so you can have you know kind
of like a collapsible item within the
drawer but definitely if you have
different entire context within the
drawer that's that's something that you
should try to avoid and I think there
were there may have been no that was it
so that was the entire that was the
entire kind of type of redesign we did
for this app now before we you know move
on I just want to say the app itself is
is designed very well it performs really
quickly the the image loading is very
good so it's a very very solid app and
this is also a beta so it's not quite
out yet it's a great app you should
definitely check it out but these are
some of the ways in which we would kind
of improve the navigation as well as you
know separate out the concepts of
navigation from actions such as
filtering with that should we move on to
design consistency name yeah that's all
right so this is a topic they're being
chewing on for a little while and I
think it's something that a lot of
people struggle and struggle with out
there and understanding how do you
design for Android and how do you have
that consistent with with the rest of
your brand and application and so on out
there so when we talk about consistency
there's a few kind of dimensions we want
to kind of redefine and really kind of
dig into and the first one is like about
cross-platform so obviously there's a
bunch of different and OS platforms out
there which you and say you know your
application your service whatever might
be probably wants to be present on so
there's got to be an element of
consistency and so users know how to use
your application across these
the next dimension we think about is
kind of like your branding really like
so even if you're running on these
different platforms you want to be
recognizable as the same service and how
do you kind of achieve that and the next
submission we think about so when we're
talking specifically about Android
Android obviously has its own look and
feel its own interaction patterns and so
forth kind of wrapped up in the in the
holo design language and the Android
design patterns so how do you kind of
like reconcile being consistent with
that so there's a lot of kind of like
confusion and choice out there so to
tackle those we kind of break it down
into three kind of design disciplines so
we're going to talk individually about
your information design your interaction
design and your visual design and kind
of how to be consistent with those so
first up the information design like we
really know Android or the holographic
and the holo design language really
isn't going to economic take you or tell
you anything here there's nothing you
know stopping you from using the same
information architecture that you use
say if you already have a web property
or a different platform you know this is
all down to your application I think
this is just comes down to good design
you know where you want to sit down and
like map out what the base entities are
in the information architecture of your
of your application and but Android
isn't gonna implementers at all so it is
all kind of on you what kind of like
slider map I guess that the point I
wanted to make here is that you the
information design especially for apps
that are information architecture
especially for apps that have an
existing potentially very large user
base or existing property you know on
the web or other mobile platforms you
don't want to compromise your your
information architecture you don't have
to choose a completely different
information architecture just for
Android so when you look at Android
don't think of it as designing a
completely separate app it's really how
do I map my existing information
architecture my existing entities the
objects I deal with the sibling
relationships of things have you mapped
those on to Android so it's really in
this case in the information
architecture portion of the design
process you really have to think about
you know how do i best communicate my my
existing
my current content and manifested in an
Android friendly way so if you take a
look at an example of Gmail for example
a property which existed on the web and
elsewhere long before Android came along
Android does not dictate anything at all
about this you know he's obviously using
some hand Roy interaction patterns and
visual design here but the information
architecture there basically and
messages conversations labels and so
forth this is purely dictated by the
product by Gmail so Android has no
bearing yeah yeah and it's very
important to make sure that when a user
comes from the web to Gmail not that
they immediately see the same exact
things like you don't want them to see
the exact same you know visuals maybe
not even necessarily the exact same I
guess ordering of content but you do
generally want them to immediately
understand where things are and what you
know kind of that all the things that
they expect to be there are there right
so the next slice we're looking at is an
interaction design so here we say that
it is actually more important to get a
lot closer to two holo and to the
Android design patterns then to anything
like really really a spoke the reason
being that while users kind of like
might know your brand and so on when
they're on in the context of a mobile
device when I'm on my Android phone and
I'm using you know multiple apps like
it's very important that your
application works the same way as the
rest those applications that can be used
side-by-side so this is where I think
interaction patterns such as the
navigation are really really critical
that a user instantly knows how to use
your application and some users will
have multiple devices maybe different
OSS you know what I might use the
website for one thing and the phone for
something else but in our kind of a
research and experience users tend to do
like kind of a context switch when they
switch between these devices so I don't
expect you know an application on an
Android phone to function exactly like
the web site I expect it to function
like an Android app and I kind of expect
that to happen and one thing one kind of
like point we wanted to make is that
bespoke interactions which kind of key
to your brand are fine that's absolute
okay but it's kind of if you do have an
interaction which is at odds with the
Android design patterns it's working out
where it makes sense to back off and
where it makes sense to do something
more than spoke as an example kind of
outside of the mobile context I mean on
websites right or on the web
you have the full breadth of HTML and
CSS and styling and stuff to kind of
communicate your your content right but
almost every website at the top left
they have a logo their navigation is
either at the top or along the left side
and that's really just something that
that's in the culture and kind of the
core of the web right so people kind of
expect that so that's that's something
where you know you want to you know take
your your information architecture your
content you know bring it to the web but
you want to make sure that you use
interactions that are very understood on
Android or not on Android on the web and
it's the same thing on Android so now
you really want to make sure that when
you come to a platform you bring your
stuff you bring your luggage and stuff
but you kind of put it into the right
kind of parts of the house effectively
nice so examples of this we're going to
take a look at so we've got four things
which are kind of slightly beyond
they're kind of like stock arrangement
of components so here isn't that app
example from Grand Street if you haven't
seen it or heard of it it's a recent
addition to our beautiful apps
collection on Google Play to love the
app and so here they're doing saying you
know quite custom in a way they're
trying to like give as much real estate
in space to kind of imagery and
description in a very very beautiful way
so they're bringing very much their own
kind of personality in their own
information architecture here but
they're kind of blending that with the
Android design so when it comes to
things like navigation and performing
important actions here they kind of like
get much closer to the action bar
paradigm so while it's not kind of a
stock action bar it's been customized
slightly and it's very very important
that users kind of familiar with that
and kind of understand all right this is
how I navigate hierarchically or this is
how I perform actions or this is where
I'll look for
supplemental actions exactly and the
next example is kind of like the
canonical example of that kind of
marking of bespoke interaction is
something like Flipboard so Flipboard
whole kind of value propositions brought
up and it's kind of magazines which you
can flip around so that's also a very
custom interaction for navigation which
is fine but when it comes to kind of
other other things like you know
performing actions or hierarchical
navigation they do get much closer to
the Android and design pattern so using
kind of the action bar affordances so
I'd love to see them get slightly closer
to kind of more of a stock action bar
presentation but largely they're kind of
like following the spirit of oh I know
where to look for navigation oh I know
where to look for actions to perform so
here yeah is it good examples of where
they're doing same kind of custom and
try and bring their own personalities
but marrying it with the Android
patterns so a visual design yeah so uh
last the last kind of like way we look
at it is looking at the visual design so
this is really a mixture of both your
own kind of look and feel along with the
Android so the idea here is to blend
your brand your own identity with the
envelope and fill so one example of this
might be things like coloring for
example while holo visual language talks
about you know stripping backs and
minimum making conflict in content speak
it's not going to give you any kind of
advice about what colors are what
palette you should use in your
application this is where you have the
opportunity to bring your own
personality to 100 out and really kind
of like make it instantly recognizable
as your brand so here is this little tip
that using a single accent color works
really really well to bring that so if
we go on to the next example which we
picked which is which is fine you know
here they're doing that trick using that
single strong accent color this really
recognizable kind of minty Thai green
color
while this is like you know pretty stock
actionbar it's instantly recognizable
instantly branded they've done a really
nice job of marrying and you know
Android visual design and with their own
branding their end up India and also
that you know we do we do make some
suggestions on color on the design site
but they're really just suggestions it's
not like every app must follow these you
know use these colors but for a kind of
smaller UI elements where you need like
a special green or red or something you
could pick those but for the core
branding we won't tell you of Android
apps must have you know these colors as
kind of their their core accent colors
it's really up to you right and the next
example I want to show is from the
Google Play suite of applications so
these are some screenshots taken from a
recent show we did on the Play and Play
Store redesign and this is within what
one application the Play Store but it
shows a very nice variation how you can
use things like like customizing the
stock components like the action bar
background the selected tab indicator
the button color just by using color
here you instantly have this kind of
branded feel I know when I'm in the kind
of a music application I know when I
switch the movies kind of context or
what I'm in a book context and then this
goes much deeper like some of their you
know text boxes a hint of the same
colors and some of the touch feedback is
kind of coloring the same way so
basically they use color really really
well to give this strong sense of them
identity so it's using you know pretty
stock Android components but using but
you know bringing their own brand that
ran identity to yep
so yeah just as a quick summary just to
wrap it up like these are kind of like
where we feel some areas where it's all
about your own information architecture
your own kind of object model and that
Hollow is not going to Android design
isn't gonna inform you and interaction
design would say was the other way it's
very important that you user knows how
to use your app as soon as they install
it or they come to it with very little
context but the visuals come is very
much a kind of a marriage between your
own branding and well I think I want to
point out I was just on the interaction
piece some of the examples that we
talked about footboard and Grand Street
you know some of the most obvious
interactions on Android are swiping and
scrolling and I'd say that both of those
apps footboard does a little bit more
custom but Grand Street especially they
you know it looks very very custom but
you know as soon as you open up the app
you kind of start swiping around and
things just work as expected so rather
than kind of doing really custom
gestural stuff to do basic things like
you know like navigate through content
you know just rely on existing features
existing gestures like scrolling swiping
horizontally things like that and users
will almost instantly know how to use
your app on top of obviously using the
same navigational model things like the
action bar up affordance spinners tabs
things of that absolutely yeah so it's
not like they're an all-or-nothing
discussion right it's not you can't say
I have to be consistent with my
application because I'm already on other
platforms and people weren't you know
how to use my app there absolutely are
elements which you should be consistent
to but there's some elements which it's
really important to get closer to the
kind of Android patterns exactly all
right I think I think that was it so
with that thanks everyone for joining I
don't know when we'll have another
episode Oh actually wait there's one
thing that we forgot to mention so we
don't have a design news section today
but one bit of design news is that we
did it kind of recently announced our
beautiful design collection that Nick
alluded to it's a set of 11 apps that
the Google Play and actually the Android
design team thought were really really
awesome so definitely check it out if
you haven't you know I believe it's
still available on your on your phone if
you just you know open up the Play Store
or go to apps and scroll that's a
beautiful design you should see it but
just in case we do have links available
so with that thanks everybody as always
I'm your host Roman Nurik
and I'm Nick butcher see you guys next
week or the week after or something like
that see